a groundbreaking today for a much needed
veterans resources center in the valley
it will be in north las vegas on
centennial parkway in pecos by the
skyview ymca jeremy j ford spoke to
veterans and city leaders about how the
new center will help those who served
[Music]
this is something that the veterans
community in nevada has needed for a
very long time michael kelly is the
chairman of the veterans resource center
he tells me the facility will be
innovative and the first of its kind in
the state of nevada is having a
government owned government run
veteran resource center a place where
military veterans of all branches can
meet congregate and receive the best
help veterans will feel comfortable to
receive health and wellness and healing
and just participate in our greater
north las vegas community a community
that ward 2 councilwoman pamela
goins-brown says is supportive of we
chose this site just because of the
close proximity to our veterans hospital
and there is a need and then we are
right here close to the ymc as well for
physical activity after or before coming
to the center
offering services for those we often
thank for serving our country they may
know that there are resources available
but how to access those they know
exactly what they need that's going to
benefit their situation once it's
finished and once it's completed we look
forward to seeing as many veterans
participate and come by as possible in
north las vegas jeremy j ford live local
now
the new center is scheduled to open by
the end of the year christian